[Music]
silent bobbin it hadn't said anything
yet cuz it's hot [ __ ] it's 90 degrees
already ten twenty ten twenty five but
over time others it's coming out when
kids so I didn't know if I was gonna go
for it but I'm going for it but I am
sans pal I don't have Shecky with me
this is too much heat for her she's 14
men like yesterday after we stopped she
she stopped after we stop streaming she
sent it so I had to wind up carrying her
like those pictures of Jesus carrying
the lamb around his neck [ __ ] threw
it around my neck he's carrying her out
and it's hard enough to take this hike
without the likes of Shecky slow my fat
ass down so we're off at it today's
Runyon Canyon hike sponsored by this
sweet-ass team they're available at Hot
Topic hot topics doing a bunch of our
t-shirts this one is the chronicon
t-shirt they debuted comic-con I love
this year and now I'm a sweat [ __ ]
balls and if you want
I can keep it all circumspect like Bob
Miller and the Muller report thing
hearing that I watch this morning
keep it es nose I don't have that
ability it's how I know I'd be a
terrible prosecutor defender statesman
politician I talk too much
you need to be a listener in that world
and me as like cinema voice too much I
guess all right today's the first free
day I've had in a couple weeks man so
I'll be riding on this thing that me and
Mark have been talking about on Batman
Beyond but no show no Khan nothing to
get to just data max relax baby die a
top Runyon in this heat I'll tell you
right now I'm glad I left this Dexter
behind man she's been roasting too hot
dog and I don't relish the thought dad
jokes dead god dammit I punch myself
alright some cats ask him why you do why
are you doing this just to force myself
to do this so if I know I'm about to do
this if I got a documented there's proof
countability kids that's what it's all
about
there's a lot of activity passing a
bunch of people bunch of cats getting
healthy Oh classroom of cats hiking
Runyon oh hi
now we're in the hi officially begins
like right here that's a pretty sweaty
walk here from my house and then the
real struggle begins can't guarantee I'm
gonna make it real long this time but at
the same time almost want to keep this
running in case that do drop out from
heat exhaustion or whatever I'm like I
have your legs you guys could be helpful
reboot Roadshow dot-com the reboot James
I'm Bob reboot roadshow to are continues
to sell very well thank you very much so
much so that we're adding extra shows in
a lot of the markets we've already sold
it so if you wanted to get tickets never
sold out check back a lot of places are
adding second show thank you let's do Oh
tough to sell when you're out of breath
just have to wear it out when your heart
is rebelling against you as is much
prettier than me buzz ain't erase kids
some people say it's not sprint it's a
marathon I just keep it to the same to
race because if it is I'm out who I
don't want race barely a member of the
human race I certainly won't to run only
when chased who alright sounds begging
down start no wish to Christ but I had
started this an hour ago
gonna walk like this the old
Christianity comes out where I'm like
Jesus helped me help me up this hill or
more importantly Jesus don't let me die
in the heat roll down the hill even more
important than that Jesus still let me
die in the heat we're all down the hill
so my shirt pulls up and then I fall
down I'm a big guts exposed in death and
that's the last picture everyone's got
and then Jesus is like he made Dogma
count on that [ __ ] happenin brother I'm
like brother then we find out Jesus
there's a whole coke and fan he's like I
love wrestling always have I gotta be
honest with you that's easier without
the mind
especially when she breaks it down puts
on the brakes for a little dog she has a
lot of stopping power now I could
appreciate other people's dogs without
my dog attacking them once again yeah
sure is the move
fix my see that slick elbow hot topic
soon I J
chainsaw Bob calm lots of new merch from
the movies share it spins action figures
from diamond it's gonna be fun if you're
into buying the crap and ephemera he'll
be there and just make me a promise if I
die on this thing you'll buy a lot of
that merchandise who I hate exercise I
hate vegetables I hate exercise
and yet I'm a hiking vegan [ __ ] heart
attack I know what when this is done
I'll feel better is the idea
I'll definitely feel sense of
accomplishment productivity and he'll
burn off some of this excess fat that's
still carrying around who somebody asked
me on Instagram today by always stretch
your neck out in pictures like your
[ __ ] turtle it's cuz even after you
lose the way it's about droopy
skinny push the skin out all the way and
when the weight goes away side the skin
comes right back or we retracts so [ __ ]
drapey and droopy so I do that so hey
don't look so obvious
I got like turkey neck or since this
[ __ ] where do you see in the turtleneck
it's cute post that put up about seeing
this kid Adam for years comic-con my
home a man got out of it was bro you got
turtle me so I love social media keeps
you honest still not at the halfway mark
kids was hoping this was the bench up
here and all my Amer and that perhaps
we've gotten to the bench not the case
miles to go before we sleep look at the
beautiful view ah
smoggy hot Austin needles paradise whoo
we're getting up to the water fountains
there is a hallmark of sorts we're
almost somewhere the water fountains is
probably my best opportunity send this
while still alive nobody wants to watch
me die I almost did once one [ __ ]
pretty shirt pulling up so I'll say
thanks for this port
give me half way up Runyon I'll do the
rest by myself I've got a deck his go to
tackle your Runyon
you